white liberals in this country will call
us bigoted uh ethnocentric and so on
xenophobic they'll say that we're
bigoted and xenophobic and callous and
cruel if we won't take gazin refugees
and yet they will not say that about the
Middle Eastern countries that are right
there and have already said red line
we're not taking a single one of them
they're not I'm not going to say that
about them it's just like every other
country they can build a wall on the all
of they can build a wall around their
entire country they can militar their
border it's it's completely
understandable we don't blame them for
that yeah we're the one country where
it's an issue